empathy in the workplace i'll show you
what it looks like because and by the
way please stop saying soft skills we
talk about hard skills and stuff there's
nothing soft about them number one and
number two heart and soft are opposites
and i would hate to think that hard
skills and soft skills are working
against each other it's hard skills and
human skills and for somebody to truly
perform i'm going to teach you hard
skills which are the skills you need to
do your job and i'm going to teach you
human skills which are the skills you
need to be a better human and if you can
master both of those you will thrive at
this organization
and i and i think that we need to double
down uh on those on those human skills
so what does empathy look like in the
workplace again nothing soft about it
incredibly human so the old system prior
you know a non-empathetic uh
scenario fairly normal you walk into
someone's office and say um
your numbers are down for the third
quarter in a row um we've had this
conversation before um if you don't pick
up your numbers in the fourth quarter
i don't know what's going to happen
right that's a
fairly normal scenario here's what
empathy looks like um your numbers are
down for the third quarter in a row um
we've talked about this before
are you okay
what's going on
i'm worried about you
right and the injection of humanity
in a human enterprise
pays dividends
um and this is the thing that's i think
so fascinating about leadership in
general is we actually don't know the
things that we say or do that actually
have an impact positive or negative i
might add you know and they're moments
of truth
like every single one of us has had an
experience uh
that we've done to someone or someone's
done to us that we thought that was so
innocuous we didn't even realize that
for example you know somebody did that
somebody asked me how i was how i was
doing they thought nothing of it went
about their day and ten years later we
still carry that gratitude to that
person and that loyalty
um and and and i think we forget you
know just
just how important showing up and
in our messy and perfect human way
trying to be a version of our best
selves
amongst each other every single day and
by the way all the talents and skills
you teach at work about good leadership
the act of listening the how to have
difficult conversations all these things
every single one of those will translate
back home you'll see marriages the
quality of marriages improve you'll see
the quality of relationships between
parents and their children improve
because of the skills that the the
the office is teaching them how to
better
you know interact with clients and
colleagues
it it's how to interact with human
beings and so all of the companies that
i know that teach these skills
the the number one feedback they get is
my marriage is better and my
relationship with my kids is better